and so the Academy presents a technical
achievement award to Joe man Savitch
Matt Dirksen and hands ripe Kemah for
the right Rhythm & Hues rigging systems
please come
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here we go we'd like to thank
the Academy in the dis community for all
their hard work I mean it's been awesome
than investigating all this stuff it's
pretty great thanks to our family and
friends for all their support and
putting up with all of our long hours
listening to us talking about rigging
thank you to John Hughes obviously for
creating environment John here's the
great environment they gave us the
freedom do an experiment and do whatever
we wanted
however we wanted whenever we wanted
whether that was good for him or not
I don't know thanks to the entire bootie
team especially Peter Wong sherry Pratt
Brad Pugh and for their leadership as
well as will tougher for his essential
contributions and all the artists that
rhythm in Hughes for trusting us and
just having their faith in us
for crazy ideas that we had go rigging
yeah
Thank You professor for acknowledging
the fact that our tools helped make your
pupils give their special abilities and
special thanks to the Academy for
awarding rigging the most awesome part
of the visual effects pipeline and it is
extremely satisfying to get an awards
for rigging because it has been our
passion for such a long time and I love
you pay in a letter and thanks for
making life outside of work
most excellent it's hard to follow that
up I'd like to thank Hans here for being
an excellent collaborator for almost two
decades and format for being what I
would call relentlessly brilliant and
using and misusing the tools that we had
provided and creating things that we've
met we didn't think they were intended
to do and then to use those same tools
to create better tools the Delta mush
was his brainchild which was a big saver
for us I'd also like to think my boys
Evan and Cole who should be at the
Indiana Jones trilogy that's playing in
Santa Monica right now but they're not
they're having a party at our house and
to my wife Rachelle further for the boys
and for herself for their endless
support and encouragement through all
those years and for Rachelle for saying
that the job in LA sounded a little more
interesting than a job in Iowa no
offense to Iowa thank you very much
you
[Music]